the US economy is on Pace to grow six
times faster than the FED predicted at
the beginning of the year and to
completely avoid the recession that just
about every major Investment Bank
predicted would happen stocks are
jumping with the NASDAQ up by more than
35% so why does everyone seem so bummed
it's not just that the Vibes are off
there are three big reasons why the US
is in an economic expansion but a
confidence recession falling real wages
declining affordability and a rising
imbalance between Americans debt and
their savings it really is all about the
numbers consumer confidence is lower
than it has been 93% of the time since
1978 that decline in confidence has a
lot to do with what's happening to
Americans pay the latest data show that
Americans wages are still Rising but by
some measures they are no longer keeping
Pace with inflation meaning real wages
are falling the latest CPI inflation
report showed real average weekly
earnings Rose in November but had fallen
in October for the third month in a row
us households earning less than $71,000
a year have seen their disposable income
decline for five straight quarters in
addition to the stagnating wages many
Americans are seeing some things are
getting much more expensive a new study
from Real Estate brokerage from redin
found that the average monthly mortgage
payment in the US has more than doubled
since 2013 and has risen by more than
$1,400 since 2020 redin study also found
a record low 15% of homes were
affordable this year a 42% decrease from
2022 which had previously set the record
for lowest number of affordable homes
redin defines a listing as affordable if
the estimated monthly mortgage payment
is no more than 30% of the local
County's median income child care
payments have also jumped significantly
according to internal data from Bank of
America the average child care payment
per household has risen by more than 30%
since 2019 and buying a car has also
reached record levels of in
affordability car shopping website
Edmonds found that a record high
percentage of consumers who financed
their vehicle were paying more than
$1,000 a month falling affordability and
the decline in real wages have led to
Americans taking on billions more in
debt while putting Less in their savings
the US personal savings rate hit 3.8% in
October that's not only below the
long-term average it's less than half
according to government data going back
to 1959 Moody's also found that
Americans earning between 21,000 and
around $71,000 a year have had a
negative personal savings rate for 5
quarters in a row so not only have those
folks been unable to save for more than
a year most of them have been spending
more money than they're bringing in that
imbalance is showing up in debt levels
us household debt balances increased by
$228 billion in the third quarter alone
according to the New York fed and after
credit card balances Rose by a record
$154 billion in the third quarter
Americans now have more than $1 trillion
of credit card debt for the first time
ever we're also seeing a significant
increase in Americans who can't pay off
their loans defaults on Consumer loans
Rose to the highest level in more than
10 years last quarter put all this
together and you can see why even with
falling inflation booming stock prices
and a strong job market Americans aren't
feeling all that confident these
days